ونبقى مع احلام العبدلي مع وقفتنا الاولى
مع مراسلي مساء العربيه احلام يسعد مساكي
اهلا بك رمضان كريم
رمضانكم مبروك وسنين دايما مثل ما نقول في
تونس
اهلا بك يا احلام احلام كنت اتابع معكم
المشاهد
كنت اتابع معكم المشاهد الجميله لسلطه امك
حوريه تقريبا من اشهر انواع السلطات والتي
سميت على اسم امراه كان اسمها حوريه وكانت
تصبغ شعرها بالحناء فتم اخذ الاسم من هذه
الاسطوره وهذا ما يتداول عن اسمه هذه
السلطه
حبيها لامك حوريه هذه حكايه السلطه لا انت
تحبيها امك حوريه سميت كذلك انا احبها
كثيرا هي اكله جميله ولذيذه جدا ومغذيه
وكذلك هي اكله في متناول البسطاء وجميع
الناس ونسبت الى امراه كانت اسمها حوريه
وتصبغ شعرها بالحناء فيصبح برتقالي اللون
طيب احنا ما بدنا نشوف يا احلام بدنا نذوق
انا ونادي المره الجايه معك ان شاء الله
في تونس احلام نبلش بمسلسل فلوجه لاثار
جدل كبير في تونس وثلاثه ملايين تونسي
شاهدوا الحلقه الرابعه من المسلسل والقضاء
رفض الدعوه استعجاليه لايقاف المسلسل
حدثينا اكثر عن التفاصيل
صحيح القضاء الاستعجالي في تونس رفض
الدعوه الاستعجاليه التي تقدمت للنظر فيها
من ساعه الى اخرى كما نقول بلغه القضاء
هنا في تونس نظرا على حسب ما لدينا من
المعلومات لعدم الاغتساس فبالتالي المسلسل
يتواصل باذن قضاء لنقل بين ظفرين او ان
القضاء بالطبع رفض هذه الدعوه هناك حمله
نحن نقول يعني حمله دعايه حقيقه كبيره
صارت المسلسل من خلال الحلقه الاولى من
امكان ان نقول بين ظفرين ان المخرجه نجحت
في ان تجعل المسلسل ليس حديث تونس فقط بل
حديث العالم العربي ثلاث ملايين تونسي او
اكثر شاهدوا الحلقه الرابعه من مسلسل
فلوجه حسب احصائيات شركه
المختصه في الاحصائيات يعني هذه
الاحصائيات علميه وليست احصائيات تقريبيه
فبالتالي المسلسل اليوم هو رقم واحد في
نسب المشاهده رغم الرفض التي سحبت الحلقه
الاولى
هذا فيما يتعلق بالفن والدراما والمسلسلات
وردود الافعال خلينا نعود معك لسلطه امك
حوريه ومساله المنتجات الموجوده في
الاسواق في مخالفات اقتصاديه اليوم في
الاسواق يا احلام تبلغ ذروتها ان صح
التعبير في الايام الاولى في رمضان اذا ما
تحدثنا عن فرق مراقبه اليوم
بالفعل تفاصيل المتعلقه في ذلك
الدوله تسعى لفرض القانون على كل مخالف
وهو مما يجعل ان التونسيين ربما لديهم بعض
الامل بالا تتواصل او ربما تتراجع وتيره
هذه المخالفات احنا يا احلام نشكرك جزيل
الشكر